من بيروت الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه نبيتي عميد الياس يبدو ان
اوكرانيا
تقدما على مستوى الاسلحه النوعيه التي
حصلت عليها سواء منذ ان تم الحديث عن
دبابات ابرامز ايضا ليبرد والان مدفع
سيزار طائرات السلاح فيكتور ولكن عين
اوكرانيا لازالت على طائرات اف 16 لماذا
نتحدث عن ارقام 120 140 دبابه الابرامز
اولا ستاتي بعد اشهر قد تاخذ مده سنه ويتم
التدريب عليها في بولندا في بوزن منطقه
بوزن وهي بعيده 500
كلميه تتحدث عن كل هذا العتاب ولكن هذا
العتاب هو في القرار الرسمي يبقى التسليم
والموافقه الرسميه بالتالي التدريب
وادخالها في المنظومه العسكريه يعني اليوم
الاف 16 هي من ضمن المنظومه الاساسيه هي
معده للدعم وهي ليست للسيطره والهيمنه
الجويه مثل الاف 15 يوم يتحدث الرئيس
مكروه عن نفس الموضوع لديه ست طائرات
ميراج 2000 ستتقاعد في وقت قريب يمكن
ارسالها لانه ليس هناك من عوائق انها
عمليه مباشره بين البلد المصنع واكره
من بولندا كما تقتنع تتطلب موافقه امريكا
في بدايه الامر وهذا امر صعب ولكن اليوم
هل سيتخطى الرئيس بايدا وهو المدير
الاساسي للعمليه موضوع الاف 16 حتى الان
لا اعتقد ان هذا الامر مسموح ما العوامل
التي ممكن ان تغير راي بيضا بتقديرك
همم قد يكون هناك امر ان يكون انهيار كامل
للجبهه في اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال
وبالتالي يكون كل الاستثمار الغربي قد ذهب
سنه وبالتالي يكون عمليه تحويل او فعلا
سقوط اوكرانيا في يد الرئيس بوتين وهذا
امر انا اعتقد انه مستبعد اليوم جلال
النمط الذي يتبعه الغرب انه ان ياتي هذا
السلاح الى حاله تكتيكيه على الارض يتم
القرار وتاخذ وقت لتسليم هذا القرار هكذا
تعودنا عليه يعني اليوم اوكرانيا بحاجه
الى الدبابات للحفاظ على عمليه
الممتم الاندفاع التي حصلت في حكام وحصلت
في خرسان توقف وبانتظار واليوم الوقت يلعب
لصالح الرئيس بوتين او لصالح الجيش الروسي
ما تحقق في مخمود في اوجليدار وما شابه
همم على سبيل المثال جلال طيب عمل الوقت
كما ذكر مهم جدا ولكن حتى حين ان يكون
هناك موقف يتبلور بشكل واضح من طائرات اف
16 كيف ترى موازين القوه مسارات المعركه
الان بنظر لما قدم ووعد به الجانب
الاخراني
الفريقين يعني
المتطلبات الميدانيه لاوكرانيا او الاهداف
السياسيه لاوكرانيا تحرير كل اوكرانيا لا
يتوافق مع العتاد او الوسائل الموجوده من
الجهه الروسيه الاهداف للرئيس بوتين
ماكسيما يعني يريد كل اوكرانيا واسقاط
النظام لا يتوفر لديه العباد والوسائل
اللازمه الفريقان يتحدران يكسب الوقت يعمل
الوقت لصالح الرئيس بوتين همم تحقيق
انجازات تكتيكيه على الارض وبالتالي
للاستعداد للمرحله القادمه ولكن يبقى
الاستعداد الاوكراني متى وصول الدبابات
سرعه اثنين العدد الذي يصل ثلاثه الجوزيه
متى تجهز للاستعمال المباشر وادخالها في
منظومه العسكريه
كان بيروت الى يسالنا الخبير العسكري